j'ai passé ma vie à me cacher j'ai passé
ma vie à fermer ma gueule à avoir peur
de tout a pas pouvoir passer un
entretien d'embauché
parce que le regard des autres ne
faisait mal
[Musique]
on disait de moi quand j'étais petit que
j'étais une sans âme une peau mais j'ai
grandi en me disant que j'étais à
un peu naze que j'étais pas capable de
faire taire certaines choses parce qu'on
se moquait beaucoup de moi petit donc me
rabaisser pas mal ça a été très dur de
passer par dessus et encore aujourd'hui
dans le métier que je fais qui métier
d'humoriste quand même de monter sur
scène et de captiver un peu les gens sur
internet et sur scène je suis encore
handicapé par mon passé d'enfant
[Musique]
j'ai un petit message pour les adultes
qui souffrent encore des moqueries à
l'école mais aussi pour les enfants qui
en souffrent actuellement j'ai demandé à
plein d'artistes de s'exprimer sur le
sujet bonjour je m'appelle triste europe
1 je suis mauvais s'échapper des vidéos
sur internet et à l'école j'étais la
[ __ ]
salut je m'appelle autres gg je suis
actrice et à l'école moi j'étais la
salle petite bouche trop maigre qui n'a
qu'à s'acheter des amis j'ai reçu
beaucoup de messages de gens qui se sont
fait insulter est un enfant notamment
[ __ ] type et des petits gros gros
[ __ ] [ __ ] qui put blondasse je
voulais montrer à tous ces enfants par
tous ces témoignages que vous n'étiez
pas seul déjà et que et que vos
différences ou ce que vous reproche vous
pouvez en faire une force et c'est même
certain
alors moi je pense qu'il ya un problème
d'éducation je pense que chaque parent
devrait expliquer à ses enfants qu'il ne
faut pas se moquer les autres que se
moquer dans une autre personne écrasée
notre personne ça rend pas plus fort je
crois qu'on a du mal à croire ou à
penser que nos enfants puissent être
méchant ou des harceleurs à l'école
c'est très compliqué donc je pense qu'il
faut prendre du recul et sans en accuser
ses enfants mais quand même leur
expliquer qc faut pas faire ça il faut
pas faire ça parce que ça prouve que ça
je demande aussi aux professeurs en fait
toutes les personnes qui encadrent des
enfants dans n'importe quel endroit une
école un centre aéré une colonie de
vacances et un club de danse d'être
vachement plus vigilants on sous estime
tout le temps quand on est enfant j'ai
amplement nous sommes embêtés ça me fait
très mal et honda c'est des gamins ça va
c'est des conneries de gamin il faut pas
oublier que le harcèlement scolaire
c'est très grave il ya des gens qui ne
s'en sortent pas et des gens qui vivent
toute leur vie en s'isolant il ya des
gens qui se suicident
il ya des gens qui meurent à cause du
harcèlement scolaire il ya des enfants
qui font des tentatives de suicide et
qui se suicident et d'ailleurs j'ai
envie de dire aussi aux enfants qui
voient le harcèlement scolaire qui voit
des gamins qui souffrent à l'école s'il
vous plaît allez les aider je vous
assure que quand vous serez grand quand
vous serez à l'utt
vous serez hyper fier de vous